THANKS, JOHN KIRBY.
COME BACK SOON.
>> WILL DO.
>> Martha: ALSO WITH US NOW,
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, MARTHA.
>> Martha: YOUR THOUGHTS ON ANY
OF THE ABOVE.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU?
>> YOU BEGAN THE CONVERSATION
AROUND THE ISSUES IN IRAN.
TODAY WE HAVE APPARENTLY IRANIAN
BACKED MALITIAS ATTACKING OUR
EMBASSY IN BAGHDAD.
I'VE SEEN A CLIP OF THE VIDEO
WHERE THEY'RE THREATENING TO
KILL PRESIDENT TRUMP AND MYSELF.
>> Martha: YOU HAVE SEEN THE
VIDEO?
>> WE HAVE NEGOTIATORS AT THE
TABLE IN VIENNA.
>> Martha: CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT
THE VIDEO?
WHAT IS IN IT?
>> YOU KNOW, THE REPORTING SAYS
IT WAS A VIDEO IN A ON THE TEST.
THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT MADE
CLEAR THAT THEY WANT VENGEANCE
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ME
FOR THE STRIKE THAT WAS TAKEN
AGAINST GENERAL SOLEIMANI THAT
WAS THREATENING AMERICAN LIVES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION.
I RECOMMENDED IT TO HIM.
WE KEPT AMERICANS SAFE.
TODAY WE HAVE NEGOTIATORS WITH
THE IRANIANS WILLING TO GIVE
THEM MONEY, RESOURCES, POWER
TOOLS TO CONTINUE TO BUILD THEIR
TERROR NETWORK.
IT'S AN ENORMOUS MISTAKE.
PUTS ISRAEL AT RISK AND GULF
STATE FRIENDS, SAUDI ARABIA AND
THE EMIRATES AT RISK, KUWAIT.
ALL THROUGHOUT THE REGION AND
PUTS AMERICA AT RISK AS WELL.
I CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHY WE'RE IN
VIENNA NEGOTIATING WITH AN
IRANIAN REGIME ATTACKING
DIPLOMATS IN BAGHDAD AND
THREATENING SENIOR OFFICIALS.
>> Martha: THIS IS A SOUND BITE
FROM JEN PSAKI.
IS THIS FROM NOW OR -- THIS IS
FROM YESTERDAY.
THIS IS WITH REGARD TO THE JCPOA
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
PULLING OUT OF THAT AGREEMENT.
HERE'S WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY THEN.
>> THE FACT THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT RIPPED UP THE NUCLEAR
DEAL MEANT THAT I RAN'S NUCLEAR
PROGRAM WAS NO LONGER IN A BOX.
NO LONGER HAD THE MOST ROBUST
INSPECTION REGIME EVER
NEGOTIATED, NO LONGER HAD THE
TIGHT RESTRICTIONS ON NUCLEAR
ACTIVITY.
>> Martha: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THAT, SIR?
>> YEAH, SHE'S LIVING IN A
FANTASY WORLD DISCONNECTED FROM
THE REAL WORLD THAT WAS THE
JCPOA.
IT CREATED A CLEAR PATH FOR A
NUCLEAR WEAPON AND AN ENTIRE
PROGRAM OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT
THE IRANIANS WOULD HAVE HAD
POSSESSION.
IT'S SEVEN YEARS ON OR ALMOST
SEVEN YEARS.
IT WAS SIGNED IN 2015.
MANY OF THOSE TERMS HAVE EXPIRED
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION APPEARS
TO BE BEGGING THE IRANIANS TO
ENTER AN AGREEMENT THAT WILL RUN
OUT IN A HANDFUL OF YEARS.
IT DOESN'T PREVENT THE RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH I RAN HAVING A
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
WE WERE RIGHT TO GET OUT AND WE
HAD FOUR MORE YEARS, THE
AYATOLLAH WOULD HAVE BEEN FACED
WITH A DIFFICULT DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER TO CAPITULATE AT RISK TO
HIS CONTINUED AUTHORITY OR TO
SIGN A DEAL WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK THEY WOULD HAVE DONE
THAT AND WE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN A
DEAL THAT PRECLUDED I RAN FROM
ENRICHING URANIUM AND
THREATENING ISRAEL AND THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Martha: THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION KEPT PROMISING
THERE WAS A BETTER AGREEMENT BUT
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
WEATHER NEVER SAW IT.
>> I WISH WE HAD ANOTHER FOUR
YEARS.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE HAD IRAN
ON ITS KNEES.
THEY HAD LESS THAN 10% OF THE
FOREIGN EXCHANGE RESERVES WE
DENIED THEM MILLIONS IN OIL
SALES.
NOW THIS ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
SUPPORTING THE RESTRICTIONS.
WE SUPPORTED THE IRANIAN PEOPLE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
GIVING SOURCES TO THE THEOCRATS
RUNNING IRAN TODAY.
>> Martha: AND YOU
HEARDSECRETARY OF STATE KIRBY
SAYING THAT THERE'S NOT
DEESCALATING.
THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER
SAYS IF THEY DON'T GET WHAT THEY
WANT IN TERMS OF NATO, THEY
WOULD CONSIDER PUTTING MILITARY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN VENEZUELA OR
CUBA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YOU KNOW, CLEARLY NOT
DEESCALATING.
JOHN HAS BEEN AT THIS A LONG
TIME.
IT'S DIPLOMATIC LANGUAGE.
CLEARLY NOT DEESCALATING WHEN
VLADIMIR PUTIN BELIEVES THAT SHE
CAN RUN ROUGH SHOT AND LOOK AT
COERCIVE CONTROL.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
HE'S DOING THIS IN KAZAKHSTAN
AND BELARUS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS LET HEM
CLOSE DOWN PIPELINES IN THE
SOUTHEASTERN UNITED STATES AND
DID NOTHING IN RESPONSE, THIS
WEAKNESS CREATES THE SITUATION
AND WE'LL PUT REAL RESOURCES
RIGHT IN OUR SPACE, RIGHT IN
VENEZUELA AND RIGHT IN CUBA.
THESE ARE REAL RISKS WHEN YOU
HAVE DETERRENCE, LEADERSHIP
PREPARED TO PROTECT AMERICAN
INTEREST.
YOU CAN PREVENT PUTIN FROM
THINKING ABOUT HEADING DOWN THAT
PATH.
I HOPE THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL
BEGIN TO USE AMERICAN POWER, DIP
ME -- DIPLOMATIC POWER AND ALL
OF OUR TOOLS TO KEEP THEM FROM
GAINING POWER AND STRENGTH AND
THREATEN AMERICA.
>> Martha: WENDY SHERMAN, WHO
WAS THE LEAD NEGOTIATOR OR ONE
OF THE TOP NEGOTIATORS IN THE
JCPOA IS THE LEAD NEGOTIATOR IN
THE DISCUSSIONS GOING ON WITH
RUSSIA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT SHE SAID THE U.S. OPEN TO
THE DISCUSSION ON PLACEMENT OF
MISSILES IN EUROPE?
>> SUPPOSE IF YOU GOT THE RIGHT
COMMITMENT FROM THE RUSSIANS AND
THE CHINESE ABOUT THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAMS AND THEIR NUCLEAR
CAPABILITIES AND THEIR STRATEGIC
AND OPERATIONAL MISSILE SYSTEMS,
I SUPPOSE YOU COULD IMAGINE
THAT.
BUT MRS. SHERMAN BEING THERE
DOESN'T GIVE ME MUCH HOPE FOR
THAT SHE WAS NOT ONLY INVOLVED
IN THE JCPOA BUT SHE NEGOTIATED
WITH A NUCLEAR DEAN WITH THE
NORTH KOREANS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION DID NOTHING.
WE SHOULDN'T LET THE RUSSIANS
DICTATE OUR POLICY.
SHOULD BE AND DETERRENCE IN
EUROPE AROUND AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT'S HOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS.
I HOPE THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL
THINK ABOUT DELIVERING REAL
DETERRENCE AND PROTECTING